- All right, man, what's up?
My name is Vandaveon Huggins.
This my nigga Mike Taylor
right here, man.
We want to talk to people.
Want to talk
about "Key & Peele," man.
That's our shit, dawg.
That's our new show, man.
We love it, man.
That's our jam,
straight up, man.
- Shit's stupid, man.
- The shit is stupid, man.
Shit is funny as hell, dawg.
- This nigga's stupid.
- And we know, man.
We comedy writers
ourselves, man.
We be writing sketches
every day, man.
Mike and I, man,
we working at TSA.
We work security
at the airport and whatnot.
Man, it's crazy.
We make everyone laugh.
We make our coworkers laugh.
Everybody think we funny, man.
- Straight prank.
- We doing pranks, man.
Do, like, prank shit,
you know?
Oh, man, it's funny as hell.
Mike be saying some ad libs.
- You got some--you got
a dick in this suitcase?
- [laughing]
It's like--it's like
exactly what he do.
He's talking about,
"Hey, man, hey,
Excuse me, sir, you got a dick
in your suitcase?"
This nigga talking about,
"No, no, I don't think so."
- I said that.
- [laughing]
- I said it.
- Oh, man, y'all need
to hire us, man, for real, man.
We love the show, man,
but seriously,
there's, you know,
a couple scenes in the show
weren't working for us,
you know what I mean?
- Got some problems
in it, though.
- You want to come here
and sit with me,
or what you gonna do, man?
- Nah, nigga,
this your shit.
- You sure?
- Yeah.
- You all the way
back there, dawg.
- Don't be stupid.
- You gonna be talking,
or what are you doing?
- Being stupid.
- All right, man.
But anyway,
y'all had this one scene.
Y'all was two dudes
who was married,
and y'all was scared
of your wives, and whatnot.
- That was stupid,
though.
- And then y'all
was looking around,
trying to talk
some shit about them.
Y'all was like, "Bitch."
- Bitch.
- It was like, "You a bitch."
- You know what I mean?
[laughter]
- That is stupid,
though.
- Watch this--
- That's the--
- What?
- You--
- Yeah, watch the video, man.
- Darrel, I looked my woman
in the eye sockets.
- Mm-hmm.
- I told her straight out.
I just said it, man.
I said it, I said, I said,
I said...
I said, "Bi--"
both: Hey, guys.
- Hey, girl, how you doing?
- Oh, hey.
- You having a good time?
- You had two niggas,
like, scared of their wives.
Ain't no nigga
scared of his wife.
Could, like, you know--
like, the first time
you seen the women,
like, they was talking,
and then they, like,
turn into giants, and whatnot.
And then they turn into giants.
Then these niggas
really be scared for real.
- Dragons, man, dragons.
- Dragons--oh, dragons, yeah!
They could be dragons.
No, tell them, man,
tell them, tell them.
- No, no.
- Go on, man.
- No, nigga, you.
- Shit, okay,
like, dragons too, man.
Yeah, dragons, man.
They could be dragons
and whatnot.
You know what I mean?
These niggas be, like,
sitting here,
I told her, you gonna tell me
to get out the shower
and drive the car,
I said, "Bitch..."
Wah!
- [screeches]
- This nigga just get burnt up.
He just got burnt up
like a match stick.
That would have been my shit
right there, dawg.
- Nigga being stupid.
- That'd have been my shit
right there.
- Nigga being
stupid right now.
- Dragons, that's my shit.
- You being stupid.
- Nigga said dragons.
Tell 'em,
you had another idea, man.
Tell 'em, man.
- Samurais, nigga,
samurais.
- If these bitches
are turned into samurais, man,
that would have been my jam!
- Cut a nigga's dick off.
- [laughs]
Like, they wouldn't know
they was hiding in the trees
or something like that, right?
- Cut a nigga's
dick off.
- He was saying
they hiding in the trees.
And they going,
"I says, 'Bitch.'"
And them bitches jump up,
talking about, "Say-say-say!"
And cut these niggas' dicks off?
Nigga, shit!
- You being stupid.
- That's how you could
make it funnier, dawg.
We ain't saying
it wasn't funny.
- That shit could be
a little bit better, though.
- We're saying you could
make that shit funnier, dawg.
- Even funnier with us.
- We on your side, man.
You should hire us.